we received a lot of questions online
mr. Trump about the tape that was
released on Friday as you can imagine
you called what you said locker room
banter you described kissing women
without consent grabbing their genitals
that is sexual assault you bragged that
you have sexually assaulted women you
understand that I didn't say that at all
I don't think you understood what was
that this was locker room talk I'm not
proud of it I apologize to my family I
apologize to the American people
certainly I'm not proud of it but this
is locker room talk you know when we
have a world where you have Isis
chopping off heads where you have and
frankly drowning people in steel cages
where you have Wars and horrible
horrible sites all over where you have
so many bad things happening this is
like medieval times we haven't seen
anything like this the carnage all over
the world and they look and they see can
you imagine the people that are frankly
doing so well against us with Isis and
they look at our country and they see
what's going on yes I'm very embarrassed
by it I hate it but it's locker room
talk and it's one of those things I will
knock the hell out of Isis we're going
to defeat Isis Isis happened when number
of years ago in a vacuum that was left
because of bad judgment a bad judgment
and the bad had created a vacuum in my
head but because of crooked Hillary but
nasty nasty woman Isis was born under
one one star out of Hillary's bad
judgment the top of your head and the
proud of it
I apologized to my wife my family and my
mirror for the horrible horrible sight
they have to bear every day but grabbing
a cane or kissing a woman without asking
it's still better than chopping off
heads and drowning innocent little
kittens
and woolen bag on a lonely lake on
Sunday and that's what I think about it
excuse me mr. Trump with all due respect
I didn't understand a single word you
just said
did you really just compare the hideous
crimes of Isis with your sexual assault
on women no II didn't not at all
maybe maybe I did yes that is possible
maybe not to be honest I can't remember
and I don't want to but let me ask you
one question is it really the right time
water-cooler chitchat about some
harmless locker room talk about him
highly hypothetically grabbing while
Isis let's hang out and clear these are
Maryville times so what we need is a
medieval president like me all of my
thinking and my treatment of women is
outright maybe I'm not proud of it but I
love it a lot it's a crime I tell you
what is a crime everything that crooked
Hillary has that she invented that
pieces because she is an evil evil woman
and when I'm president I promise I will
put her on trial and personally trouble
her nasty wicked head Manu Trump I'm
sorry to interrupt again but I really
think you're getting off track here can
we please get back to my question yes
yes yes I'm more than glad to answer and
I will tell you right now I'll tell you
what I will do to stop Isis which
terrible there are a bunch of rock
people not as crooked as crocodilly but
still very very very evil and I will
stop Isis I will build a wall to stop
them very cheaply by illegal Mexicans
well afterwards stay behind where I can
wait to kill to clean the house of their
own people and our also build a
tremendous glass dome over America to be
the safe from rain and the so called
climate change which doesn't exist it
doesn't exist at all it's an invention
of the Chinese but I will defeat it
anyway I'll grab that will seize climate
change by the sea control back to China
that's what I'll do I promise if I'm and
I'm sorry but we really have to stop
this debate I don't think you're ever
going to answer my question about the
remarks you make you're wrong you like I
did as I said it's locker room talk but
it's not my fault
cook till we had more than 30 is to
something to outlaw local talk because
it stopped forever when she was in
Congress I didn't so if I say but I want
to grab it is really she was grabbing
the plate because she didn't stop me
from saying oh I just okay I think
you've completely lost your minds now
your nurses will be here any moment but
we have to say goodbye to the people No
thank you no no no no no you can't stop
me now nobody can and please me when I'm
sitting on the president's throne in the
White House
in King's Landing I swear to God which
is me anyway I will make sure but no
president of this great country will
ever have to answer stupid questions
like this again as long as I am American
president
I pray that will never happen yeah you
know we were saying never underestimate
the power of stupid people in large
groups and now you can count our
population and call me mr. president
[Music]